all right a lot of a lot of news today I
don't even know where to begin exactly
but I guess we'll begin with the most
obvious thing President Trump gave a
speech in the Rose Garden this mornin
declaring a national emergency so that
he could build the wall now he is also
signing a disastrous 1000 plus page
spending bill that would undermine
undercut undo everything that he's been
trying to do with respect to the wall
it's more than a thousand pages like I
said so nobody's read the whole thing
with par for the course these days
nobody knows exactly what's in it we
just kind of you know just sign it and
and you'll find out it's fun to find out
after you've already signed the thing
it's like one of those one of those you
know you went to when you went to
birthday parties when you were a little
kid and they gave you a little little
prize little gift bags a little prize
bags and which was a good thing that
even everyone had to get a gift at a
birthday party right which is maybe why
Millennials have grown up to be such
whiny babies is because we grew up you
know when we grew up even we got
birthday got presents and other people's
birthday parties anyway um so thousand
pages nobody knows what's in it
but we do know some of the highlights or
the lowlights I guess we should say
Daniel Horowitz a conservative review
has a he's been on top of this had a
good write-up at that website and he
gives us five insane provisions in the
bill including just 1.3 billion dollars
for the wall or fence no wall by the way
is allowed to be built with this which
will cover only 55 miles and that is
instead of the 25 billion in hundreds of
miles of wall that Trump originally
wanted it's also less than the one point
Sachs six the one point six billion that
Democrats originally agreed to so things
have gone down the deal was negotiated
down Democrats end up with something
better for them than their original
offer the bill also prohibits any
fencing on federal or state lands what
and even in the small slice of area
where the fence can be built local
officials who happen to be
Merl hey for the most part
coincidentally in the little piece of
area where where they're allowing the
fence to be built just so happens that
those are more liberal controlled areas
and oh by the way the local authorities
can veto the construction you have to
get their their approval and if they
don't approve it's not gonna happen so
of course what does that mean it means
that probably from this bill
nothing will be built at all more from
Horowitz it says there's more funding to
manage and induce the invasion of
immigrants rather than to deter it while
offering no new funding for ice
deportation agents or immigration or
immigration judges to speed up asylum
claims as the president requested this
bill adds another forty million dollars
for the alternatives to detention
program which moves asylum seekers to
facilities in the interior of the
country also the doubling of low-skilled
workers the bill doubles the number of
h-2b non agricultural unskilled seasonal
workers who will continue to be a public
charge on America there's there's a lot
of other stuff but it provides amnesty
for the sponsors of unoccupied minors as
well the bill is just is as I say a
disaster as for the national emergency
part of this Trump speaking of disasters
Trump had his chance to get up in front
of the country make his case for it from
the Rose Garden to explain everything
that's going on to sign a national
emergency is a it's a it's a drastic
step right everyone can agree with that
whether you support it or not we all
agree it's a threat you're saying
emergency right so you put yourself into
the shoes of the president let's say
you're the president you're gonna be
signing a national emergency and using
that as a way to allocate billions of
dollars to fund this project that you
want to do okay well when you have a
chance to get up
America and make the case for it
wouldn't you want to make sure that
you've got a very coherent cogent speech
that you're going to give it isn't that
what you would do but instead I don't
know if you watched the Rose Garden
speech but it was a it was a it was not
good
I keep I wanted to say disaster but I've
been using that word way too much it was
not good he rambled for 20 minutes and
barely offered one coherent sentence in
the whole thing
going back if we was talking about China
and talk about North Korea jumping back
and forth to various different topics
doing the kind of thing he does at his
political rallies which I guess if
you're into that kind of thing and you
like to hold the whole shtick at the
rallies I'm personally not a big fan of
it but when you're giving a speech at
the Rose Garden to explain a national
emergency that you just signed this is
not the time to just get up with no
preparation and no prepared remarks and
just ramble not the time for it it was
just bad and of course I'm watching the
reaction on social media and most people
were cringing at it and saying okay this
is this is this is catastrophic for the
president politically but I also saw
there were you know Trump's most loyal
supporters and fans were say oh this is
great this is wonderful
yeah he's talking straight this is this
is what we like these we need more of
this now see you're not helping first of
all you know if you watch the speech you
know that it was not good you know that
so to pretend otherwise why are you
pretending and you're not helping don't
encourage the president to do that more
often
look we all look everyone agrees you
watch the the State of the Union speech
is a brilliant speech great performance
all around right very compelling
well all of that is now a distant memory
it's been buried under this under
everything since let me ask if your
supporter of the president do you think
we should have more of the State of the
Union type moments or more of what we
saw this morning at the Rose Garden what
do you think is more compelling what do
you think is going to be more convincing
to people
especially those who are not already
huge fans and totally bought in the
people that are more in the middle the
people that by the way the president's
gonna need if he wants to get reelected
in 2020 now if you if you are a if you
are all in and you're a big fan of the
president then he's already got you yeah
no matter what he does and says you're
gonna vote for him right so he doesn't
need to appeal to you
he needs to appeal to everybody else and
the rambling off-the-cuff
riffing off-the-cuff thing it doesn't it
isn't it's only appealing to people like
you not to anybody else
so as far as the national emergency
itself you're going to hear of course
extremes on both sides against Trump's
most loyal supporters and fans are going
to call this and are calling it a move
of brilliance a win so on and so forth
it is it is not that this is not a win
it's a way out it's a way around it's
the thing you do when you don't win a
win would have been build wall a win
would have been a bill that allows them
to actually build a wall that's a win
this is a this is Plan B or Plan C now
whether it's a good plan B whether it's
a good way around that's another
question
but then the usual suspects on the other
side they're they're all losing their
minds of course as they do with
everything Trump does claiming that this
is some kind of constitutional emergency
it's a catastrophe
it's tyranny it's he needs to be
impeached and yadda yadda yadda well
that's not the case either presidents
have been declaring national emergencies
for frivolous reasons for a long time so
even if you think this is a frivolous
reason well this he's not the first one
to do that Obama was certainly a culprit
Obama also rewrote our immigration laws
by executive Fiat so this is not new now
if we can point out that other
presidents have done it that doesn't
necessarily mean it make it good but
that does mean that you can't really
panic over it or treat it as
unprecedented especially if you weren't
panicking when other presidents did it
so it's not a constitutional catastrophe
it's also not a big win I think it falls
somewhere in the middle I think that the
main problem with it is that it is a
political stunt that will not lead to a
single mile of fence actually being
built especially when you combine
combine it with the spending bill that's
the problem with it not a constitutional
emergency but it's not gonna do anything
in fact Trump even said in his speech
that he knows he C went on this whole
rambling riff about how it supports good
we're gonna get sue then we're gonna end
up to the course they're gonna go to a
different chord now we're gonna be in
the Supreme Court now he knows exactly
what's gonna happen and he knows there's
a good chance he's gonna get shot down
he knows that of course he knows that
now
should he be saying that when he first
signs that I mean when you're signing a
national emergency you shouldn't say
publicly yeah by the way you know I'm
gonna get sued for this but of course
he's gonna get sued so that's no
surprise and it seems unlikely to me
that the courts are going to be on his
side with this whether or not they
should be it seems unlikely that they
will so there's at least a very good
chance that nothing will come of this
and that's my problem with it
a
another thing though is you're hearing
from some conservatives that they're
worried is that now this sets a
precedent and so the next Democrat
president is going to do the same thing
and we're going to get a national
emergency declared over climate change
and and the president is going to use
that as an excuse to do whatever they
want to do appropriate whatever money do
whatever they want maybe we'll get a
national emergency over guns gun
violence is a national emergency and
maybe they'll use that and somehow be
able to confiscate guns I mean so you've
got conservatives worrying about that I
understand that concern it is not a
unreasonable concern but I think the
Democrats will do that anyway so I'm not
in the camp I don't think that Democrats
are waiting for Republicans to set a
precedent before they do it
Democrats don't need the permission of
Republicans to do something like that
to me it is all but certain even aside
from this it is pretty much a certainty
that the next Democratic president will
declare a a climate change emergency
because they really do think that it's
an act they think it's a global
emergency they think and their base
certainly thinks that we are on the
verge of extinction as a as a species
because of climate change
and so it is regardless of any of this
even if Trump was never elected I think
it's was always a certainty that we were
going to get a national emergency
declared of a climate change eventually
and and then whatever comes of that
probably the same for gun violence so I
think we're heading in that direction
regardless III can't join the
conservatives who have I think it's a
reasonable concern but I also think that
probably it would happen anyway my main
objection is like I said it probably
won't amount to anything but then the
second part of that is we had two years
there were two years prior to this where
the wall could have been built and you
wouldn't have needed a national
emergency you wouldn't have needed any
of the theatrics you wouldn't have
needed to shut down the government and I
know
could say well Mitch McConnell and you
know they he wouldn't allow the the
Republican establishment wouldn't allow
it to happen and yeah they they deserve
a fair amount of the blame but Trump at
any point during those Paul Ryan you
know is the other one that gets blamed
but during any point in those two years
if Trump had taken the stand that he
took once Democrats got into office and
said no we are doing this now I am NOT
signing anything until it happens if he
had done that with Republicans the ball
the wall would have gotten bill 100%
yeah they may have been resistant to it
but he has leverage over Republicans see
the thing is once Democrats got into
office once they controlled the house it
was a lose-lose situation there was no
way it was gonna happen because
Democrats have no reason to ever agree
to building a wall their base doesn't
want it their donors don't want it there
they all hate Trump so why would they
ever agree to something like this of
course in it politically would make any
sense for them so Trump has no leverage
over Democrats at all none he does have
plenty of leverage over Republicans so
if he had put his foot down and said
we're doing this now and then any
Republican who refuses well then they
would have their constituents and their
base coming after them but Trump didn't
take that step for those two years he
said he wanted it he complained that he
didn't get it you know he made gestures
towards it a few times but nothing like
this it was until Democrats got in that
he was willing to shut down the
government and if necessary declared
national emergency if he had that kind
of determination for the two years
leading up to this the wall would be
they'd be building it right now that's
the fact and you could not you cannot
absolve Donald Trump of all guilt in
this as much as you might want to you
can't it's absurd
so what we have now is Thea this is just
theater all of this is theater and it's
gonna end with nuts gonna it's going to
amount to nothing if this was a bad
about actually getting something done it
could have been done all right I've got
to move onto something else before I
have a an aneurysm just everything about
this just pisses me off everything just
everything and everybody all sides
everybody I'm just sick of everything
and everybody and I want to go live in
the woods
I want to just take my family and go
live in the woods you know in a cave
somewhere subsisting on honey and wild
locust much like John the Baptist all
right meanwhile news broke yesterday
that police suspects Jesse Jesse Jesse
Smollett may have staged the hate crime
attack in Chicago two weeks ago the hate
crime attack in Chicago two weeks ago
then after those reports surfaced
Chicago police denied or at least said
they could not confirm that that was
actually true that they were
investigating whether or not it was
staged but what we do know and what has
not been denied is that the two persons
of interests most likely the two guys
who appear on the security camera
footage remember police have a security
camera footage of Jesse smollett's
entire walk back from Subway except for
60 seconds they've their only missing 60
seconds and the only other people who
appear anywhere on that footage are
these apparently these two guys who they
now have in custody or they are
questioning now these two guys are
Nigerian and they are apparently
brothers who what do you know worked on
the show Empire with Jesse Smollett hmm
so I mean could they be Nigerian
rednecks that could they be Nigerian
racist rednecks who uh I mean is that
what we're gonna hear next from the left
look it was clear all along that this
was a hoax right I've already gone off
gone over
all the holes in the story it was
literally unbelievable from the start
but then once the video footage surfaced
and you could only see a 60 second gap
in this whole altercation was supposed
to have happened in 60 seconds well then
you already know that it should that
that's enough that's all you need to
know of course it didn't happen nothing
about the story was remotely plausible
in fact we don't even have to get we
don't have to look at any of the
specifics we just we don't we just look
at the fact that Smollett was claiming
that two racist skinheads essentially
would recognize a supporting cast member
from the show Empire as he's walking by
in the dark at 2:30 a.m. now I guarantee
you that almost that anyone who has true
anyone who falls into this category some
kind of crazy psychotic white
nationalist type of person not only have
they never seen Empire but they probably
don't even know that that show exists so
that detail alone made it impossible to
believe but everything else is just
icing on the cake and it's just you
can't believe it
now I never thought though that he
necessarily staged the attack I figured
that he just made it up
he invented the attackers out of whole
cloth that would certainly be a smarter
move because at least if you invent
imaginary people then the cops barring
any barring any actual video evidence of
when the thing was supposed to have
happened they could never conclusively
prove that you did that it didn't happen
if you just invent people that never
existed then the cops probably will
never be able to prove that you made it
up because it's all in your head and
they can't read your mind but if you
enlist real people into the ruse and
then the cops find them and they confess
to it under legal pressure well now
there is positive proof that you lied so
to actually involve people and do some
sort of staged thing it just doesn't it
doesn't why would you do that so is that
what small like that I I don't know the
involvement of these two Nigerian men
who worked on the show certainly adds a
lot of credence to that to that notion
by the way small it's clearly full of it
the only question that remains is is how
will the left deal
with this okay they really have three
options they can either defend him and
and say that he was traumatized from a
life in Trump's America so he can't be
held responsible for his actions or they
can say that yeah you know you lied but
he started he started an important
conversation about race and sexuality in
America and let's focus on that so they
can do that or they just ignore it and
pretend it never happened those are
really their three options or there is a
fourth option they could be so ticked
off at him for embarrassing them and
undermining their narrative that they
actually do condemn him forcefully which
is much like they did with Kevin Spacey
remember Kevin Spacey after he got in
trouble for these several abuse
allegations by by teenage boys Kevin
Spacey tried to deflect by coming out of
the closet and saying yeah I'm a gay man
as if that was the headline and I think
he thought that that would get at least
liberals to come into his corner but but
it didn't work they turned against him
all the more because he was trying to
draw this association between
homosexuality and his and his sexual
abuse and they didn't like that at all
so he ended up being even more of a
pariah a similar thing could happen to
smullin because he is embarrassing the
left and undermining their whole hate
crime narrative so who knows a few other
points about all this first is think
about the media's role in in this and
just consider their performance over the
last few weeks we don't even have to
think about I think just think about the
last few weeks
first they run with they run with this
out of context video clip of the
Covington Catholic students and they
paint them as racist and they tell a
version of the story that turns out to
be false and they remember they took
that first version they reported it
uncritically without any sign of
hesitation or skepticism and then when
the true story came out the media for a
while tried to stick to its original
narrative and continue the lie and then
when that became impossible they just
dropped it and moved on like it never
happened
and then right on the heels of that we
have this Smollett thing once again they
took the first version of the story they
reported it uncritically many headlines
in the first few days said things like
Empire actor assaulted in hate crime
attack
no no alleged no reportedly they just
putting it out as a fact amplifying the
ridiculous story the guy was telling
without even showing any signs of
skepticism and these people these people
in media have the gall to get offended
when we call them fake news we've got
all the ammunition we need just from the
last three weeks forget about the last
two years or thirty years just from the
last two weeks we have all that all the
reason in the world to discount most of
the mainstream media as fake news fake
news is the most flattering possible
thing we could call them if we wanted to
be more accurate we could call them
sniveling shameless lying manipulative
propagandists and I think that would be
more accurate
second thing just to think about is if
America is this is this is a brainteaser
if America is such a racist country
why do liberals constantly have to
invent fake hate crimes we see these
fake hate crimes all the time it's very
common especially after Trump was
elected but if America is so racist why
do you have to invent it if America is
so racist it seems like if you're a a
black gay man for instance there should
be plenty of real-life examples of the
persecution and abuse that you've faced
yet you're going and in coming up with
fake ones it seems like
this seems to indicate possibly that
America is not actually a racist country
America is in fact probably the least
racist country on earth and it is so not
racist that you have some people in this
in this country who are so desperate to
be victims and yet they find so little
supply of real victimhood they find so
few opportunities to really be a victim
that they have to invent it this is what
we talked about a few days ago that
people in this country are from a very
young age are raised to see victimhood
as a desirable thing we see victimhood
as power victimhood equals power and so
people are desperate to be victims they
see it as some sort of trump card that
they can always play a trump card that
they can use to win any argument to get
sympathy whenever they want it to get
job opportunities whatever and if they
can't really be a victim then they'll
make it up but that tells you something
that if these if these if these frauds
would just stop it I mean think about
there's that the famous line from
believe owes Morgan Freeman it was
interviewed on 60 minutes several years
ago and you see this clip pop up on
Facebook a lot where he's asked first
what he think if he likes Black History
Month what he thinks the Black History
Month and he said he doesn't he's not a
fan of it and then he was asked well you
know what do we do about racism in
America how do we how do we stop racism
and and Freeman said stop talking about
it
just stop talking about it and this
this is coming from you know an elderly
black man who when he was growing up he
really did experience severe racism and
this is coming from him I think there's
a lot of truth there there's a lot of
wisdom to that that if we would just
stop trying to make race and issue all
the time stop inventing hate crimes stop
looking for every opportunity to paint
someone as a victim someone as the you
know persecutor we would just stop doing
that we could almost maybe really live
in something close to a post-racial
America maybe not across the board for
everybody but there are a lot of people
that you know they just when you're a
kid if you grow up at a diverse
environment and there are a lot of
different races and religions and
different types of people you're growing
up with you're going to school with them
you're hanging out with them after
school then that's just your it just
wouldn't even occur to you to be racist
because that's just your environment you
just take it for granted when I was
growing up I went to a very you know I
grew up in a very diverse area went to a
school with with a whole range of
different sorts of people both we're
talking race ethnicity socioeconomic
backgrounds everything you know and it's
very common for a lot of people
especially be live on the on the East
Coast like I did and I remember growing
up all it just never even race never
even I never even saw it as an issue at
all when I was in first and second grade
and you know I was in school and we had
Hispanic kids in class and black kids
and Asian kids and white kids Jewish
kids and just I didn't look around and
see oh there's so much diversity look at
that well you have that sort of person
over there and that sort of person over
there no these are just kids these are
just my classmates these were just
friends which is what we're supposed to
want right isn't that the kind of
country we're looking for but it seems
like what happens
especially with you know academia and
the media is they see that and they come
in and they try to interfere with it and
they say no no no no no no no no no and
especially they start saying to the to
the you know to the black kids oh no
that well that's that's a white kid over
there he's you need to be suspicious of
him so he's got privilege he's got all
these things you don't have and all
these advantage you need to be
suspicious and he's inherently racist
and they say to little girls no those be
careful the little boys over there are
they're dangerous toxic masculinity and
they say they say to the kids who have a
who come from you know have who come
from less wealthy families they say oh
look at those look at the kids over
there their families have more money you
should hate them for that no that's they
shouldn't have that money
it's not fair look all these things they
have that you don't have and they start
whispering into the ears of kids like
like serpents like snakes trying to
engender hatred and division and racism
and envy and everything and they're
successful and then you end up with guys
like Jesse Smollett a fraud and a liar
who would make up something like this
and in so doing he is he is trying to
paint an entire race of people as
potential psychotic violent bigots
all right one other points before we get
to some of your emails Amazon was
speaking of well this has to do with
what I've just been talking about Amazon
was supposed to build a massive new
headquarters in New York they were gonna
hire 25 25 almost at 2,500 they were
gonna hire 25,000 people and open a base
of operations in the city but after
pressure from liberals like Alexandria
Kaiser Cortez who didn't want Amazon in
the city because Amazon is a big
corporation and big corporations are bad
now Amazon has changed their plans and
they won't be going there and bringing
all the jobs the jobs and the positions
will be filled elsewhere like places
like Dallas and other places so Cortez
spiked the football yesterday on Twitter
she said anything is possible today was
the day a group of dedicated every day
New Yorkers and their neighbors defeated
Amazon's corporate greed it's worker
exploitation and the power of the
richest man in the world this is to be
clear a politician celebrating that
25,000 new jobs won't be coming to her
city she's bragging that she helped to
prevent her constituents from getting
jobs which is total madness what we see
now on the left is is a complete
investment in class warfare this goes
back to the sewing division that I was
just talking about and they're all in on
this so it's not just about race and
gender and creed and sexuality anymore
now it's definitely about how much money
you make so we've got we've got Cortes
boasting about kicking jobs out of her
City we've got Elizabeth Warren sharing
pictures of rich guys on their yachts
and saying oh he shouldn't be able to
buy this boat you've got Democrats
screaming and Howard Schultz for
committing the crime of being
financially successful Howard Schultz
who by the way I'm no fan of him the
guy's a you know left-wing I disagree
with him on many subjects but he lived
in the projects when he was a teenager
he started with one little coffee shop
in Seattle and he built it into a
billion-dollar ant enterprise
and our worship as Americans that's the
American dream right early there used to
Alysse it used to be to start from
nothing with one little with one little
seed and to plant it and to have it
sprout into something incredible that
used to be the American dream and we
used to admire men who were able to do
that but now we have Democrats saying no
don't admire them they are they're
thieves
somehow Howard Schultz is a thief
somehow he stole I don't know how
exactly he built up his own operation
made his own money but these he stole
somehow the fact that he has billions
and I have less than billions well
that's his fault he's been he's been
reaching his hand into my pocket
invisibly and stealing from him no for
me I don't buy it it's just it's just
unamerican it's unamerican
to look at rich people and hate them for
being rich now on the other side of it I
also don't think we shouldn't worship
wealth and I think sometimes on the
right
among some there are certain types of
conservatives who can venture a little
bit too close to the idol worship of
rich people and money and success and
all of that and I'm not on board with
that we shouldn't worship money and also
on a personal level you shouldn't hoard
your wealth you should help the less
fortunate willingly through your own
volition through your own choice not
because you're forced to by the
government so I believe that but I also
believe that Envy is not American that's
not supposed to be an American value and
it's not healthy and certainly not
Christian and we should
admire success now worship it but we
admire it because it takes it takes a
certain brilliance ambition you know
creativity ingenuity to go from nothing
to something that's that's American to
admire that this though what we're
seeing with the Democrats this is not
this is I don't recognize this I don't
recognize this as American alright um I
guess we'll jump we'll jump ahead to the
to some of your emails before we wrap up
for a Friday because I have a few really
good ones that I don't want to miss you
can always email the show remember Matt
Walsh show at gmail.com had a few people
just kind of chiming in on some of the
topics we've been talking about this is
from ash
she says hi Matt take it on thinking on
this Jesse smollett thing tonight and I
am really mad if this proves to be a
hoax
and as of 1:00 a.m. mountain time it
appears to be that way then it is
undeniable proof that the left has
weaponized racism as a means to silence
and intimidate conservatives I grew up
in Atlanta Georgia the Old South and 80s
90s I have experienced real racism and
seen older generations of racism up
close making false claims about this
especially if he actually made a noose
and put it on his own neck is a bridge
too far this is so wrong as a mother
raising three white males I am pissed
off that a rich incredibly privileged
actor can perpetuate racial stereotypes
of white men and falsely claim that
something this horrific was done in
their name and you will probably get
away with it too and didn't his Empire
co-star make false racism claims about
her son recently as well I don't know
about that I haven't heard about that
with the media's complicit complicity
this feels very much like a coordinated
attack on conservatives specifically
white male conservatives as a mom and as
American I'm outraged the media is
absolutely to blame for the America we
find ourselves in they have way too much
power I give thanks and praise to God
for alternative media and for you guys
at the Daily wire sincerely thank you
for everything you do Matt
ash I thank you for that and I
completely agree with what you're saying
and I sympathize with it and it makes me
angry too although I will say that yes
this is this is more proof that the left
has weaponized racism but
is certainly not the first piece of
evidence that we have for that this is
from Brittany is she says on the subject
of drag queens I do feel offended by
what they do not in this not necessarily
because it's disordered which it
definitely is but because of its
influence on girls in our culture as a
teacher I see the way young women dress
into their makeup everyday drag has had
significant impacts on the makeup trends
that we see on the internet and in
schools one drag queen in particular has
his own makeup line which you markets to
women and girls girls are wearing masks
like makeup with drag queen like
eyebrows gigantic false lashes and
overlined lips as well as overly
contoured features they look fake and
feel the need to wear this kind of
makeup but they ironically no longer
look feminine because of it thanks for
bringing this up I think that's another
excellent point I think well I think
girls and women are harmed in many
respects by a lot of this gender
non-conforming stuff this you know this
idea of of gender being this fluid thing
so that a man can actually be one I
think women are harmed many in many ways
not the least of which being when you've
got men coming into bathrooms and locker
rooms with with with your daughter but
this is another angle as well I
appreciate you bringing that up this is
from Jessie says hey Matt love the show
I have a question for you please how can
you reconcile not believing in the death
penalty with the existence of truly evil
people why should Gosnell El Chapo Bundy
Mason Manson that is etc be allowed to
sit behind bars for life on everyone
else's dime when they could never be set
free if there's another if there's
eternal life what's wrong with releasing
them for judgment a bit earlier and
removing our responsibility of
protecting ourselves from that evil hi
Jesse well it's not necessarily the case
that I don't believe in the death
penalty I've waiver on the issue back
and forth I've I flip-flopped on it I
admit quite a bit I've never been in
principle against it absolutely as in
I've never felt that there's no
circumstance where it's okay I've never
believed that for a while I was of the
opinion that it's only ethically
appropriate in third world countries and
those sorts of situations where they
don't have the prison infrastructure to
segregate dangerous people from society
for decades
but recently I have expanded my view
I'll admit I've realized that when you
have someone especially someone as evil
as what you just described if you're
going to keep them imprisoned for
decades that requires I think an undue
and unfair burden on the public on the
taxpayer because if you think about it
some people are so evil so horrible so
monstrous that even their fellow inmates
won't tolerate being around them so
these people have to be held in
protective custody forever for their
whole lives or you could have people who
are so dangerous and so sociopathic and
so manipulative that you can't risk
having them around other prisoners
because you don't know you know you
can't risk them kind of sort of starting
their own little prison cult and trip
being able to manipulate prisoners and
get them to do their whim
so either way when you have people like
that the manson types and we can't
execute them then the only other option
is to hold them in protective custody
solitary confinement for their whole
lives and so we have to ask ourselves
are we really morally required to keep
someone in protective custody solitary
confinement for decades just to protect
them because their crime was so heinous
that even their fellow murderers don't
want to be around them and I think no I
don't think so I I think in the end that
doesn't seem a cycle to require that of
the public and of the taxpayer and of
society and you could even argue that
it's actually less humane to keep
somebody locked in solitary confinement
for 50 years that just to execute them I
was reading about where they're probably
gonna send El Chapo I mean they're
sending out chapo to to this fortress in
and I think Colorado and he's gonna be
in solitary confinement in a little
concrete box for 23 hours a day for the
for the next however many decades I
guess they have no choice but to do that
but is it even okay could we even say
that's more humane than execution so I
agree with a lot of what you're saying
there Jesse all right finally I for
whatever reason I've gotten like three
emails in the last few days about
basse aliens did i talk about space
aliens recently maybe I did maybe that's
why but I've got three emails all with a
similar point or question and I want to
address that quite the question is
basically this if there is intelligent
life elsewhere in the universe and I
believe there is but if there is how
does that work theologically in other
words wouldn't this other race or these
multiple other races when they have
their own salvation histories and how
does that happen did Jesus go to all
these planets and how would that work if
Jesus is fully divine and fully human
and he went to some other planet would
that make him fully human fully divine
and fully Klingon or whatever it isn't
such an idea heresy so there are a lot
of difficult questions raised by the
idea of intelligent life on other
planets
and I have thought a lot about it this
is the kind of thing that I think about
all the time I think about it like every
day probably because I am mentally
unstable so here's how I respond to that
I don't have I don't have a complete
answer but here's what I'll say first of
all it seems to me that there are many
options here
you could have unfallen races you could
have races where no redemptive act was
necessary so that this kind of avoids
that problem or you could have races
that are fallen but unredeemed that's
always a possibility or they could be
fallen and redeemed some other way there
are a lot of theories about the
atonement of course but I think most
theologians agree that Christ didn't
have to die on the cross to save us he
chose to it was a choice that's the
point it wasn't something that happened
by force of necessity but by his own
free will is own choice he could have
theoretically gone about it some other
way what way well who knows I don't know
nobody does but the cross was a choice
so could it be that if there are
multiple races of fallen rational
creatures that they've all been redeemed
in dramatically different ways possibly
in ways that wouldn't even make sense to
us that would be literally
unintelligible to us if we were told
about them I think that's possible
all of that seems weird to me I admit
hard to
imagine kind of unsettling but they are
possibilities and here's the other point
I think theological challenges are
raised more so by the idea of aliens not
existing then by the idea of aliens
existing and I'll explain what I mean we
know that the universe is a very very
very very very very large place there
are something like 100 billion stars in
our galaxy that's just in our galaxy 100
billion and if each star has a few
planets then that means that there are
easily 200 or 300 billion planets
possibly more in our galaxy how many
galaxies are there well probably 100
billion at least so 100 billion galaxies
time times 100 billion stars times
however many planets on average what
does that equal it equals a lot it
equals an incomprehensible amount it
equals an amount so huge that we may as
well call it infinity I mean for all
intents and purposes we may as well say
there are an infinite number of planets
in the universe because the number is
just so big that you couldn't even write
it it would take you days to even write
the number of zeros that would be
required is it really plausible that all
of those planets all of those trillions
of planets are dead except for ours then
why do they exist in the first place
why make a universe so vast and so dead
and so full of pointless mindless
violence and explosions and black holes
and emptiness and everything if it's all
just meant to be the home of one tiny
little group of mortals on one small
speck of dust in one unimpressive corner
of one terribly ordinary galaxy I mean
yeah it could all serve some sort of
mysterious cosmic purpose that we can't
understand fine but the point is that
such an idea such a theory does raise
its own unanswerable questions and
there's a bigger question or challenge I
think keep in mind that the most
commonly used proof for God's existence
is the fine-tuning argument
okay the fine-tuning argument which i
think is a great argument I use it all
the time very forceful argument it says
that the universe was finely tuned for
life basically there are certain
constants in the universe that had the
diol been turned just a hair this way or
a hair that way would have made life
impossible and it is so vastly
improbable
if things would be calibrated this way
to make life possible that you almost
have to admit some kind of God to
explain it because it's the only way to
explain something that improbable
happening that's the argument in a
nutshell if I didn't just butcher it but
if this universe of 100 billion galaxies
with 100 billion stars apiece is almost
entirely completely dead except for one
infant essa mille little speck of dust
hiding out in one little corner of it
then it seems that the fine-tuning
argument loses a lot of its force right
because then the Atheist can just say
well it's not it's not it's not finely
tuned I mean look at the universe it's
almost completely dead what are you
talking about finely tuned for life
there's almost no life in it it's dead
they could also say that yeah life is
very improbable but the universe had
trillions of chances on trillions of
planets to roll the right combination of
dice to make life arise and so if you
mix up a bunch of chemicals on a zillion
planets it's almost certain that one of
them will turn into life that could be
their argument now I'm not saying that
it obviously doesn't disprove God if
we're alone in the universe that
wouldn't shake my faith anyway any but
I'm saying that it would make one of our
best arguments less compelling I'm
saying that a universe with 50 trillion
dead planets is finely tuned for life is
like saying I don't know it's like
walking into an abandoned shopping mall
with five stories and seeing a little
raccoon eating a stale Cinnabon over in
the corner and and coming to the
conclusion that the that the mall was
built for the raccoon it just it just
maybe it was but it just doesn't it
doesn't make as much sense but if the
universe is teeming with life which I
believe it probably is then the
fine-tuning argument is back in play
back with a vengeance because now you've
got this huge massive thing with life
all over the place and again it's you
can say well clearly it was fine control
life so in my view I think a universe
with other life presents fewer
challenges theologically than the other
option though in the end it doesn't
matter because we'll never know anyway
we will never know what life is is or
isn't out there so it just doesn't it
doesn't really factor in in the end
the alien hypothetical is just that
hypothetical but it's an it's an
interesting hypothetical to think about
in any case all right I'm glad I was
able to get my alien spiel in at the
very end there and if there are aliens
out there I could only hope that somehow
they are watching this show right now
all right
I'll talk to you on Monday have a great
weekend Godspeed everyone